This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一档iHeart播客节目。保证全真人。2%。当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数占比只有2%。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们在奇妙的现代世界中展现出的精神韧性、体能以及建立适应力的秘诀。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字 2 加上 percent，可在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我而言都是个意义重大的时刻。1984年对我也非常重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并尝试理清我们是如何熬过那段岁月的。我们将与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜爱的作家们一起探讨。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。1984年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，再没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at It。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方进行都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人身披一副铠甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造过一次测试。互联网侦探们出动了一大批人，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，这是一档我们一起探讨二十岁时面临的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to this show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode where we break down the psychology of our 20s. Today is a special episode because at the time I'm recording this and at the time you might be listening, it is Valentine's Day. And each year on Valentine's Day, I like to pick an episode to do with how we can build and sustain healthy relationships, not just the romantic kind of course, but our platonic ones as well. And how we can kind of apply psychology to better understand all the forms of love that we experience in this lifetime, specifically in our 20s, of course, but also,
大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落，非常高兴你能回来收听又一期节目，在这里我们剖析二十岁的心理学。今天是一期特殊的节目，因为在我录制这集的时候，以及你可能正在收听的时候，恰好是情人节。每年的情人节，我喜欢挑选一期节目来探讨我们如何建立和维持健康的亲密关系，当然不仅仅是浪漫关系，还包括我们的纯友谊。以及我们如何将心理学应用到更好地理解我们在这一生中所经历的各种形式的爱，特别是在我们二十岁的时候，当然，还有，
some of the concepts and theories that we should have like a good understanding of before the decade is out to really set ourselves up for good, healthy love. And in today's episode, we're going to do just that. We're going to be discussing the idea of the mental load. So I wouldn't be surprised if you hadn't already heard about this concept. This term, the mental load, has been doing its rounds on TikTok and Instagram recently. It is the latest term that has become part of the psychobabble. But I really have my good friend Aaron to thank for this episode. If you are a long-time listener of the show,
在我们迈入三十岁之前，我们应该对一些概念和理论有很好的理解，以便为真正健康美好的爱情打好基础。在今天的节目中，我们将讨论这个主题。我们将讨论“心智负担”这个概念。如果你还没听说过这个概念，我也不会感到惊讶。最近，“心智负担”这个词在 TikTok 和 Instagram 上广为流传。它是加入心理学流行语行列的最新词汇。但我真的要感谢我的好朋友亚伦，这期节目多亏了她。如果你是节目的老听友，
you will know that Aaron, my best friend, is where I get a lot of my inspiration because she thinks about these things very deeply. She thinks about self-awareness. She's very self-aware, very thoughtful. She's always introducing me to, so many new theories and ideas that I actually never came across when I was studying psychology. She's just like a book of knowledge. And last time I was visiting her, we got to discussing the idea
你就会知道，我的闺蜜亚伦是我很多灵感的来源，因为她对这些事情思考得非常深入。她会思考自我觉察。她非常有自我觉察能力，非常体贴。她总是向我介绍许多全新的理论和想法，而这些我在学心理学时甚至从未接触过。她就像一本知识的宝典。上次我去看望她时，我们讨论了
of the mental load in our relationships because we are both in very committed long-term relationships with very lovely men. And although we love our partners so deeply and they are such good people, we've chosen very well, there is a lot of invisible, mental and emotional labour that just happens to fall on women in relationships. Even if you think that your partner is very much your equal, even if they are, there is such a hidden facet, a hidden component of love and effort that sustains a relationship that women often take on. So also known as cognitive labor, mental load specifically refers to the kind of extra energy and efforts women take on in order to organize the lives of themselves and their partners, specifically in hetero relationships. You know,
在我们亲密关系中心智负担的想法，因为我们俩都身处于非常投入、长期的恋爱关系中，伴侣也都是非常可爱的男士。尽管我们深深地爱着我们的伴侣，他们也都是很好的人，我们做出了非常棒的选择，但在亲密关系中，总有许多无形的、心智和情感上的劳务，恰好落在了女性的肩上。即使你认为你的伴侣在很大程度上与你平等，即使事实的确如此，维系一段感情仍存在着一个隐秘的方面、一个隐秘的组成部分，其中包括女性往往要承担的爱与付出。因此，也被称为认知劳动，心智负担具体指女性为了组织自己和伴侣的生活而承担的额外精力和努力，尤其是在异性恋关系中。你知道的，
the time taken to plan what we're having for dinner. When people's birthdays are, what we're doing on the weekend, what we need to bring to the family gathering on Friday, the mental logistics of the week and of our lives, you know, the date night that's coming up that we need to plan and organize all of these small mental kind of gymnastics, all these small mental tasks that contribute to kind of the, I wouldn't say domestic burden, but the relational burden that each member of a partnership is kind of carrying. For example, say that you know your partner's parents are coming into town next weekend, which means we have to make plans for dinner that night that they come in but they don't like Italian food and it would have been a really long flight so
花时间规划我们晚餐吃什么。谁的生日在什么时候，我们在周末做什么，我们需要在周五带什么去家庭聚会，一周以及我们生活的心理后勤，你知道的，即将到来的约会之夜我们需要计划和组织所有这些微小的心理体操，所有这些微小的心理任务，它们构成了某种程度上的——我不会说是家庭负担，而是伴侣关系的负担，伴侣关系的每个成员都在某种程度上承担着这种负担。例如，假设你知道你伴侣的父母将于下周末来到这个城市，这意味着我们必须为他们到达的那天晚上安排晚餐计划，但他们不喜欢吃意大利菜，而且那会是一趟非常漫长的飞行，所以
we should make dinner at home which means I'll need to go to the grocery store before then I'll have to make sure the bed sheets are washed and pick up extra toothbrushes but the bed sheets can't go in the dryer so I'll have to make sure that they're getting washed on a day that's really sunny that will have to be Friday but we're out of laundry detergent so we'll pick that up as well it's this running to do list of tasks that is honestly never-ending and that I think sometimes men in relationships don't pick up on. I think we are all very aware these days of the unequal division of labor in relationships, particularly in the past, how one partner, normally the woman, just seems to be instantly more responsible for household chores, even when they work the same amount of
我们应该在家做晚饭，这意味着我在此之前需要去杂货店，我得确保床单洗过了，还要多备几把牙刷，但床单不能烘干，所以我得确保在一个阳光明媚的日子洗床单，那得是星期五，但我们的洗衣液用完了，所以我们还得顺便买点洗衣液，这是一张源源不断的待办事项清单，老实说它永远也做不完，而且我认为有时恋爱中的男性并没有注意到这一点。我想现在大家都非常清楚恋爱关系中劳动力分配的不平等，特别是过去，一方（通常是女性）似乎瞬间要对更多的家务承担更多责任，即使她们和伴侣工作时长相同，
hours as their partner or have other obligations, how women are often more responsible. for child rearing activities, domestic duties, that sort of thing. However, it goes a lot deeper than just performing the task. Women also spend a lot more time thinking about what tasks have to be done, playing almost the role of like admin for the lives of themselves, their partners, their families, even their friends. As one study published in the American Sociological Review describes it, women just spend more time anticipating needs, identifying options, making decisions, and ensuring that what they asked someone to do is actually completed. In my mind, we've all reached a point where we understand that men are expected to do more labor than their fathers or
或者有其他义务，女性往往要承担更多责任。在育儿活动、家务琐事等方面。然而，事情远比完成任务本身要深入得多。女性还要花大量时间思考必须完成哪些任务，几乎扮演着自己、伴侣、家庭甚至朋友生活中的“行政管理”角色。正如美国《社会学评论》杂志发表的一项研究所描述的那样，女性只是花了更多时间去预测需求、确定选项、做出决策，并确保她们要求别人做的事情真正完成了。在我看来，我们都已经达成了一种共识：现在的男性比他们的父亲或
the grandfathers did. You know, we do split things 50-50, but that doesn't always fully take into account the added cognitive labor that goes into getting those things. done, you know, and I think a lot of times people just partners, male partners in particular, sometimes need to be told what to do. They may respond of like, oh, you know, you're upset that I didn't do the dishes. Well, why didn't you just tell me? You know, I would have done it if you had asked. But the very act of needing to ask for help and expecting your partner to tell you everything that needs to be done means that you're kind of still treating your girlfriend, your wife, your partner as kind of like the manager of the house, the manager of the chores, the manager of your
祖父需要承担更多的劳动。你知道的，我们的确是50对50分摊事情，但这并不总能完全考虑到完成这些事情所附带的额外认知劳动，你知道的，而且我认为很多时候，人们——尤其是男性伴侣——有时需要被告知该做什么。他们的反应可能是：“哦，你知道的，你对没洗碗感到不高兴？那为什么不直接告诉我呢？你知道的，如果你要求了，我就会去做了。”但需要请求帮助这一行为本身，以及指望你的伴侣告诉你所有需要做的事情，意味着你其实仍然把你的女朋友、你的妻子、你的伴侣当作是家里的经理、家务的经理、你们
lives. It's kind of a lot like a workplace where obviously in a workplace we have like we have the employees and we have the boss and the boss is always going to be more responsible for what's going on and as an employee you go back to your boss and you ask oh what needs to be done next or some tasks that I should do but a relationship is not like a workplace you know the no one is the boss no one is the employee both people need to be truly invested in the outcome in it together looking for things that need to be done looking for things that are going to make the other person's life easier. And I don't think that that is always what occurs. You know, we understand physical and domestic labor needs to be equal, but the mental burden remains very strong. And with that, the psychological burden of having to
生活的经理。这有点像一个职场，显然在职场中我们有员工，我们也有老板，老板总是对正在发生的事情负有更多责任，作为员工，你会回到你的老板身边，问：“哦，接下来需要做什么，或者有哪些我应该做的任务？”但恋爱关系可不是职场，你知道的，没有人是老板，也没有人是员工，双方都需要真正投入到结果中，齐心协力，寻找需要完成的事情，寻找能让对方生活更轻松的事情。我不认为这总是会发生。你知道的，我们理解体力和家务劳动需要平等，但心智负担依然非常重。随之而来的还有心理负担，你不得不
overlook certain things, suppress resentment, because he's still doing what you asked, but you kind of wish you didn't have to ask and also just having less mental space for other parts of your life and your identity and your interests. I personally believe this wears down a relationship in a lot of invisible ways because maybe you can't quite articulate why you feel exhausted in your relationship or why things feel unfair. You can't tell your partner why. You just know you feel that way and I do think a lot of answers lie in this invisible, cognitive and mental labour. Now, before we get into why exactly this occurs and the impact and some solutions, I do want to make a little bit of a disclaimer.
忽视某些事情，压抑怨恨，因为他仍然在做你要求的事情，但你又有点希望自己不必去开口要求，而且这也导致你留给自己生活、身份和兴趣其他部分的心理空间变小了。我个人认为，这会在许多隐秘的方面消磨一段感情，因为也许你无法准确表达为什么你在恋爱中感到筋疲力尽，或者为什么事情感觉不公平。你无法向伴侣说明原因。你只知道自己有这种感觉，而且我确实认为很多答案都隐藏在这种无形的认知和心智劳动之中。好了，在我们探讨为什么会出现这种情况、它的影响以及一些解决方案之前，我想先做一个小小的声明。
I think this is by no means a rant on how men are terrible and incompetent and idiotic and deliberately make women's lives miserable. I don't believe that. And I also know my boyfriend listens to the podcast and I'm sure he's probably thinking that if I was saying that, some of those statements aren't particularly fair. I will say, I'm very lucky that this does not describe our partnership. My dad also was a stay-at-home dad, and I saw him take on so much more of the mental and domestic load than my mom at times. So I don't think that if we date men, if we know men, we are doomed to fail and kind of constantly be under the
我认为这绝不是在抱怨男人多么可怕、无能、愚蠢，故意让女人的生活痛苦不堪。我不这么认为。我也知道我的男朋友会听这档播客，我敢肯定他可能会想，如果我这么说的话，其中的某些说法并不是特别公平。不过我要说的是，我很幸运，这种情况并不符合我们的伴侣关系。我爸爸也是个全职奶爸，我曾看到他承担了比我妈妈多得多的心智和家务负担。所以我不认为，如果我们和男人约会，如果我们了解男人，我们就注定会失败，并且会不断地生活在
thumb of the mental load. By no means, I don't think that. And I don't want this episode to kind of like find its way onto like the anti-feminist feeds on TikTok and have a bunch of people coming at me. We are all about the science here and the psychology. And the mental load is simply an identifiable and measurable relationship pattern and factor that I've become a lot more aware of recently. And I think it really deserves some exploration and curiosity because in my opinion, it's definitely a subconscious reason why relationships struggle and fail and become unequal. We see a lot of people say, oh yeah, you know, my partner and my husband, he contributes so much, but I'm still so mentally exhausted. I feel unappreciated, but I cannot articulate why. That is, at the core of what we're
心智负担的压迫之下。绝非如此，我不这么认为。我也不希望这期节目落入 TikTok 上反女权主义的动态中，引来一堆人来攻击我。我们这里讲究的是科学和心理学。心智负担只是一种可识别、可测量的关系模式和因素，我最近对此有了更深刻的认识。我认为它绝对值得我们去探索和保持好奇心，因为在我看来，它是导致恋爱关系陷入困境、失败以及走向不平等的潜在潜意识原因。我们看到很多人说：“哦，是的，你知道的，我的伴侣、我的丈夫，他付出了很多，但我依然感到精神上精疲力竭。我感到自己不被欣赏，但我却说不清楚为什么。”这就是我们今天讨论的核心，你描述的就是心智负担。那么，让我们快速剖析一下它究竟为什么会发生。我想特别谈谈三个原因。
talking about today, you are describing the mental load. So let's quickly break down why exactly it occurs. And I want to talk about three reasons in particular. The first one is socially conditioned gender roles. The second is weaponized incompetence. And thirdly, it's just like deliberate ignorance and disrespect. I think this is the harshest reason. And I would also say it's the least common, but it's still worthwhile to discuss. I also want to talk about how the mental load applies to friendships as well, because I think that that is an aspect of this that our conversations around the mental load often overlooks. Let's. Let's. get back to that first factor, though. I want to talk about socially conditioned gender roles
第一个是社会习得的性别角色。第二个是武器化无能。第三，它简直就是刻意的无知和不尊重。我认为这是最严厉的原因。我也想说它是最不常见的，但仍然值得讨论。我还想谈谈心智负担如何也适用于友谊，因为我认为这是我们围绕心智负担的讨论中经常被忽视的一个方面。让我们回到第一个因素上来。我想谈谈社会习得的性别角色
and their contribution. We have come a long way in terms of gender equality, but that doesn't mean that boys and girls aren't still raised differently, socially conditioned differently, even with our best efforts, even with all of our progressive rearing skills and progressive ways of teaching boys and girls. That traditional way of viewing gender is still incredibly ingrained. There are centuries and centuries of tradition there. And I don't think that one or two generations is going to fully eliminate some of the stereotypes overnight. So we know that within society exists this blueprint or guidebook on what behaviors are female and what behaviors are male, what character traits are female and what character traits are male.
以及它们所起的作用。我们在性别平等取得了长足的进步，但这并不意味着男孩和女孩的抚养方式仍然没有区别，社会化塑造仍然没有区别，即使我们做出了最大的努力，即使我们采用了所有进步的育儿技巧以及培养男孩女孩的进步方式。那种传统的性别观依然根深蒂固。其中蕴含着数个世纪的传统。我不认为一两代人就能在一夜之间彻底消除某些刻板印象。因此，我们知道，在社会中存在着这样一份蓝图或指南，规定了哪些行为是女性的，哪些行为是男性的，哪些性格特征是女性的，哪些性格特征是男性的。
We all kind of know what I'm talking about, hopefully, without me needing to tell you. I'll just elaborate for the sake of it. You know, the type of typical male behaviours that are acceptable are very different from those we expect from women. Boys are allowed to be rough and independent and strong and women are instructed to be passive, nurturing, empathetic, accommodating. These are all skills and character traits that will eventually make them more likely to take on that additional cognitive, emotional and mental labour in a relationship, in a family, family in a home. Now, when we talk about social conditioning in psychology, this refers to the ways in which we learn how to act by picking up clues or cues in our environment. When we behave in a
不用我多说，大家大概也知道我在说什么。为了说明问题，我再详细展开一下。你知道，可以接受的典型男性行为与我们对女性的期望截然不同。男孩被允许粗鲁、独立、坚强，而女性则被教导要顺从、温柔、有同理心、随和。这些都是技能和性格特征，最终会使她们更有可能在恋爱关系、家庭、家庭、家庭中承担起额外的认知、情感和心智劳务。现在，当我们在心理学中谈论社会化时，它是指我们通过捕捉环境中的线索或暗示来学习如何行事的方式。当我们表现出
certain way, especially as children, we are either reinforced or punished for that behavior. The simple premise is when we are rewarded for a behavior, either through the addition of something that we want or the removal of something bad, that behavior is sustained and we learn to perform it more regularly. When we are punished, we associate that behavior with a bad outcome. Naturally, we perform it less. That is a form of learning. So when girls as children act in a way that is motherly and nurturing and accommodating, they're applauded for that with praise, with kind words, all of which are a form of positive
某种行为时，特别是在童年时期，我们会因为这种行为而受到强化或惩罚。其基本前提是：当我们因某种行为而得到奖励时，无论是通过增加我们想要的东西还是消除不好的东西，这种行为都会得到维持，并且我们学会更规律地执行它。当我们受到惩罚时，我们会将该行为与不好的结果联系起来。自然地，我们就会减少这种行为。这是一种学习形式。因此，当女童在童年时期表现得像母亲般慈爱、温柔且随和时，她们会为此获得掌声、表扬、亲切的话语，所有这些都是正向
reinforcement and it means that those behaviours are encouraged and are more likely to be performed again. In contrary, when they act in ways that are counter to gender norms, they're scolded or they're punished because it's not aligning with society's blueprints and expectations. For example, a young girl might be called bossy for standing up for herself, whereas a young boy is called a leader, he's called authoritative. He receives praise, the kind of praise that we only receive when we're kind and nurturing.
强化的形式，这意味着这些行为受到鼓励，并且更有可能再次发生。相反，当她们表现出违背性别规范的行为时，她们会受到指责或惩罚，因为这不符合社会的蓝图和期望。例如，一个年轻女孩可能因为坚持自己的立场而被骂作“专断”（bossy），而一个年轻男孩则被称为领袖，被称为具有权威性。他得到了赞扬，这种赞扬只有在我们表现得友善和温柔时才会得到。
I think that that is like a very basic feminism 101 lesson. But how it relates to psychology is that these small moments, although we might disregard them, although we might look back on them and find them quite irritating, they are actually learning experiences.
我认为这就像是非常基础的女权主义101课程。但它与心理学的关系在于，这些微小的时刻，尽管我们可能会忽视它们，尽管我们可能会回想起它们并觉得它们相当烦人，但它们实际上是学习经历。
And our young brains absorb these like a sponge and carry them with us as a guide for how society expects us to act. So from a young age, we kind of know the roles that we should be fulfilling, even if no one has explicitly told us. We are caregivers. We are givers.
我们年轻的大脑像海绵一样吸收这些经验，并随身携带它们，作为社会期望我们如何行事的指南。因此，从很小的时候起，我们就大致知道自己应该履行什么角色，即使没有人明确告诉过我们。我们是照顾者。我们是付出者。
We are meant to be responsible. I think further to this, we think about the toys that we played with as children, the movies that we watched, the kind of patterns that we were exposed to. The other example I always think of is when a female student who is studious and caring, and hardworking is made to sit with a rowdy male student and like help him do his work and help him stay focused as if she is his parent or the teacher herself when actually she is just a student she is there to learn as well in those instances though we are playing this role of kind of the cognitive planner the mental planner the one who has to have everything organized out in our brain
我们注定要承担责任。除此之外，我想我们还可以回想一下我们小时候玩的玩具、看过的电影、接触过的各种模式。我总是想到的另一个例子是，一个刻苦、有爱心且努力的女学生被迫和一个调皮的男学生坐在一起，帮他做作业，帮他保持专注，就好像她是他的家长或老师一样，而实际上她只是个学生，她也是去学习的。然而，在那些情况下，我们扮演着认知规划者、心智规划者这种角色，即那个必须在脑海中把如何完成某事的一切都组织好的人。另一个因素当然是观察学习。女孩经常通过观察父母（尤其是母亲）来学习家务职责。不管你的家庭多么进步，我的家庭就极其进步。比如，我爸爸是个全职奶爸。但仍然有些时候，我看到我妈妈承担了更多的家务。家务劳动仍然是按性别划分的。你知道，女性承担了很多家务。
for how to get something done. The other factor here is, of course, observational learning. Girls often learn about domestic duties by observing their parents, particularly their mothers. And no matter how progressive your family was, my family was incredibly progressive. Like, my dad was a stay-at-home dad. But there were still times where I saw my mom take on more of those household chores. The chores were still divided along gender lines. You know, women do a lot of the domestic duties.
男孩和男人则被分配了被认为体力要求更高、传统上属于男性的任务，比如院子里的杂务、倒垃圾。所有这些都是给我们的暗示。它们是一种学习体验，我们以这些期望为蓝本塑造自己的行为。我们模仿照顾者的行为，这就是我们成为今天的我们的方式。我们从心理学以及班杜拉的一些早期实验中得知，我们所学的大部分东西都是通过观察和复制获得的。这里还有很多其他因素。
Boys, men are assigned tasks that are perceived as more physically demanding, traditionally masculine, yard work, taking out the trash. All of these are cues to us. They are a learning experience and we model our behavior on these expectations. We model our behavior. we mimic our caregivers and that is how we become the people we are today. We know in psychology and from some of those early experiments with Bandura that a lot of what we learn is through observation and replication. There are so many other factors here.
我要说的最后一点是，我们还看到这样一种模式：与女性相比，男性被允许拥有更长的青春期。我来对此做进一步的解释。我认为，男性不负责任、犯下愚蠢的错误、不会做饭、不会打扫卫生，这些在很大程度上都是可以接受的，这很古怪，很有趣。而在女性身上，情况则有点像：你已经21岁了，你成年了吗？如果没有，你就是不够成熟。你长大的速度不够快。就像你只是在像个小孩子一样行事。男性却被允许在婴儿期和青春期以及较低责任感的阶段停留更长的时间。因此，女性才是在组织能力、责任感等认知和心智技能方面比她们的男性同伴更快成长的人。
The final one I will say is that we also see this pattern a lot of men being allowed to have like a longer period of adolescence compared to women. I'm going to explain that a little bit more. I think that it is very kind of acceptable for men to be irresponsible, for men to make dumb mistakes, for men to not know how to cook, not know how to clean, it's quirky, it's funny. Whereas with women, it's kind of like you hit 21, are you an adult yet? If not you're immature. You're not growing up fast enough. Like you're just acting like a child. men are allowed to stay in this period of infancy and adolescence and lesser responsibility for a lot longer. So women are the ones who are gaining those cognitive and mental skills around organization, around responsibility, a lot earlier than their male counterparts.
这随后体现在异性恋关系中。我认为最简单的前提是，我们之所以一次又一次地看到心智负担，
And that is then reflected in hetero relationships. I think just the simple premise is that the reason we see the mental load again and again and again. is that men have not been socialized in the same way as women to be attuned to the needs of others and to apply kind of the same level of cognitive processing as women do. It may also come down to genuine differences in personality. And I feel like I need to throw this in here. There has been a lot of research that has shown that women are more empathetic than men.
是因为男性没有像女性那样接受过同等的社会化训练，无法去关注他人的需求，也无法应用与女性相同水平的认知处理。这也可能归结为性格上的真正差异。我觉得我必须在这里顺便提一下这一点。有大量研究表明，女性比男性更有同理心。
And we know that empathy really at its core is the ability to recognize and relate to what's going on in someone else's mental. mind. That includes that invisible list of things that need to get done around the house, in the relationship, whatever it is. And it just might seem that men are not as clued into the inner workings of someone else's brain as women are, not just because they haven't been socialized that way, but also because their levels of empathy, maybe a little bit less. Empathy is a skill, it's a muscle, and I think that it can be built up if you're prepared to kind of do the work.
我们知道，同理心的核心实际上是识别并关联到他人心理中发生的事情的能力。这包括家里、恋爱关系中等各个地方需要完成的那份无形清单。而且看起来男性可能不像女性那样了解别人大脑的内部运作，这不仅是因为他们没有接受过那样的社会化训练，还因为他们的同理心水平可能稍微低一点。同理心是一种技能，它是一块肌肉，而且我认为如果你准备好做这项工作，它是可以建立起来的。
And I think if you care about someone else, if you're around them a lot, eventually you should be able to pick up on the way that they do things, what they prioritize, what they need to get done, what creates stress for them and kind of act without needing to be asked.
我认为，如果你关心某人，如果你经常和他们在一起，你最终应该能够注意到他们做事的方式、他们的优先事项、他们需要完成的事情、是什么给他们造成了压力，并且能够在不需要被要求的情况下采取行动。
I want to talk about one final aspect of the mental load and its causes here. And you know what? Maybe this might piss somebody off. I don't really mind because I think that it is highly, relevant to this discussion, and that has to do with weaponized incompetence. Again, this has been making its rounds on social media, I think, because people are getting
我想在这里谈谈心智负担及其成因的最后一方面。你知道吗？也许这会惹恼某些人。我其实并不介意，因为我认为它与这场讨论高度相关，这与“武器化无能”有关。同样，这个概念最近也在社交媒体上流传开来，我想这是因为人们
a lot more clued in to the labor that women do that isn't just domestic and physical. And in psychology, weaponized incompetence refers to a deliberate or strategic use of falsified fake incompetence or ineffectiveness as a tactic to avoid doing something, in this case taking on the mental load. Key words in that, it is deliberate, it's strategic, it's false, and also obviously incompetence. Like it's not that this person actually is incompetent. They're pretending to be so they're weaponizing it. You know, weaponized incompetence sounds like, you know, oh, you just do it so much better than me. Oh, I don't know how to do it. I'll just make more of a mess.
对女性所做的不仅仅是家务和体力劳动的贡献有了更多的了解。在心理学中，“武器化无能”指的是蓄意或战略性地使用伪造的、虚假的无能或低效，作为逃避做某事的策略，在这种情况下，就是逃避承担心智负担。其中的关键词是：它是蓄意的、有战略性的、虚假的，而且显然也是无能。也就是说，这个人并不是真的无能。他们是在假装无能，所以他们是在将其武器化。“武器化无能”听起来像是：“哦，你做得比我好太多了。哦，我不会做这个。我会把事情弄得更糟。”
You're just so much more organized. You have a system. Like, I'm just going to screw it up. Why don't you just let me know what I can help with? And by intentionally impureing incompetent, trying to elevate your ineffectiveness in certain areas, this lowers expectations for you to actually get stuff done. And it also causes you to gain sympathy whilst avoiding responsibility.
“你组织能力好太多了。你有一套系统。反正我会搞砸的。你为什么不直接告诉我有什么我可以帮忙的呢？”通过刻意表现出无能、试图夸大自己在某些领域的低效，这降低了人们对你真正把事情做好的期望。这也会为你赢得同情，同时还能逃避责任。
I've seen so many videos of this in recent months where a woman asked her husband to do something while she's away and he just does a terrible job as if she hasn't you know he hasn't seen her do it a million times or you ask him to like do your to do list or take something off your agenda and sometimes you think like this person cannot possibly be that incompetent they have a full-time job like they're probably very respected at work you married him for a reason like this has to be deliberate in some ways and you know what's worse than having to ask someone to do something it's asking they're having them do it and then you having to redo it later. It leaves you feeling really angry and disappointed,
最近几个月我看到了很多这方面的视频，视频中一个女人要求她丈夫在她不在的时候做某事，而他却做得一塌糊涂，就好像他没见过她做过一百万次似的，或者你请他照着你的待办事项清单去做，或者帮你分担一些日程安排，有时你会想，这个人绝对不可能这么无能，他有一份全职工作——他可能在工作上备受尊敬——你嫁给他是有原因的——在某些方面这一定是有意的。你知道比要求某人做某事更糟糕的是什么吗？是要求他们做，让他们做了，然后你还得在事后重新做一遍。这让你感到非常愤怒和失望，
but you also don't want to sound like a nag because at least they put in the effort. And that is weaponized incompetence. Again, we can look for the origins of this behavior. Sometimes it is learned from childhood where boys, men, are allowed to escape responsibilities and they may have learnt that if their parent has asked them to do the dishes or fold the laundry and they did a really terrible job,
但你又不想听起来像个唠叨的人，因为至少他们付出了努力。这就是武器化无能。同样，我们可以追溯这种行为的根源。有时它是从童年时期习得的，当时的男孩、男人被允许逃避责任，他们可能已经了解到，如果他们的父母要求他们洗碗或叠衣服，而他们做得非常糟糕，
or they said that they forgot, they would get away with it. And so now it's a tactic to avoid doing a task altogether. We can make excuses, we can have reasons, we can have explanations, but regardless, I think it's really exhausting, especially in like a day and age where, like, no one really has the time to be doing more mental labour than they have to. And I know we've been talking a lot about this in the context of long-term relationships where there is maybe a home to maintain or children, whatnot.
或者他们说自己忘了，他们就能蒙混过关。所以现在这成了完全逃避某项任务的策略。我们可以找借口，我们可以有理由，我们可以有解释，但无论如何，我认为这真的很累人，尤其是在这样一个时代——在这个时代里，没有谁真正有时间去做比必须做的更多的精神劳动。我知道我们一直在长期关系的背景下讨论很多这个问题，在这种关系中，可能有一个家要维持，或者有孩子，诸如此类，
but this can also occur on the early stages of dating as well if you're just like you've been dating someone for a couple of years whereby once they realize that you'll take on more of the responsibility of maintaining your lives together of course they're going to say yes to that because that's less responsibility on their plate the biggest example i think that i've been that i've seen in like friends relationships not necessarily my own but i see it quite a bit is um planning date nights. You know, you say to your partner, hey, I'd really like to do a date night, but like every time we do it, I plan it.
但这也会发生在约会早期阶段，如果你只是——你和某人约会了几年，一旦他们意识到你会承担更多维系你们共同生活的责任，他们当然会对此说“好”，因为这减轻了他们肩上的责任。我认为我见过的最大的例子——在朋友的感情中，不一定是我自己的，但我经常看到——就是计划约会之夜。你知道的，你对伴侣说：“嘿，我真的很想过一个约会之夜，但是每次我们过的时候，都是我在计划。”
I'm always the one who wants to find something fun, something that's open at 8pm on a Monday. Like, can you do it? And as the date gets closer and closer, there's nothing planned. They keep saying they'll think of something until you're at the stage where you have to decide whether A, you just plan it or B, you wait for them to do it and you're disappointed. because it's another night of sitting at home watching TV, ordering takeout. That is not what you deserve. And I think although no relationship is perfect, when you're with someone that you love and who respects you,
“我总是那个想要找点有趣事情的人，找个周一晚上8点还开门的地方。你能来安排吗？”随着约会日期越来越近，却什么都没有计划好。他们一直说他们会想个主意，直到你到了不得不做出决定的地步：要么A，你还是自己计划；要么B，你等着他们去做，然后感到失望。因为这又是一个晚上坐在家里看电视、点外卖。这不是你应得的。而且我认为，尽管没有哪段感情是完美的，但当你和一个你爱他、他也尊重你的人在一起时，
you both still need to show up for each other, even if you're not feeling 100%. You know, I think it's once again linked to that empathy thing. If your partner is like, well, I'm just so exhausted from work, I'm so tired like I never think of things. you're probably also in that same boat. Make sure you communicate that. Like they should want to step up for you to make it equal on both your parts. We also see the mental load in friendships. This, I don't think, is talked about enough.
你们俩依然需要为彼此付出，即使你感觉状态没有达到百分之百。你知道的，我认为这再次与同理心有关。如果你的伴侣说：“嗯，我工作太累了，我太累了——我从来想不到什么点子。”你可能也处于同样的处境。一定要进行沟通。他们应该想要为你挺身而出，让你们双方的付出保持平等。我们也在友谊中看到心智负担。我认为这方面的讨论还远远不够。
But I think that a lot of us relate to this kind of experience whereby our friends just begin to expect that we're the ones who will always make plans. We will make sure that the reservation is booked, the tickets are. purchased. Everyone has transportation, everyone knows what's going on. The endless list continues yet again. Friendships take effort, much like romantic relationships, and sometimes that effort can become unbalanced. You're always the one reaching out. You're always the one needing to think of fun things to do. And I think that that is an example of where someone has begun to expect you to take on the cognitive labor of sustaining the relationship. There comes to, a point where you have to evaluate if I love the saying but like if the juice is worth the
但我认为我们中的许多人都能对这种经历感同身受：我们的朋友开始认为，我们就是那个总是负责做计划的人。我们会确保预订好餐厅，购买好车票。每个人都有交通工具，每个人都知道发生了什么。无休止的清单再次延续。友谊需要付出努力，就像浪漫关系一样，有时这种努力会变得不平衡。你总是那个主动联系的人。你总是那个需要想出好玩事情去做的人。我认为这就是一个人开始期望你承担维系这段关系的认知劳动的例子。总会到
squeeze like whether this person has just come to expect you to take on all the mental energy of sustaining your connection and what is that making you feel like how is that making you feel the answer is probably not amazing probably not great because you never want to feel like a relationship is unbalanced in such an extreme way you know, you don't want to feel like someone is not mirroring your efforts, because what does that say about the respect they have for you, the respect they have for your connection, the respect they have for your relationship? I think it takes so much mental energy to initiate a conversation about these things, and maybe you don't have it in you. You devote even more of your finite cognitive
这样一个地步：你必须评估——我很喜欢这句名言——这是否“值得”（if the juice is worth the squeeze），也就是这个人是否已经习惯了让你承担维系你们联系所有的精神能量，这让你作何感想，这让你感觉怎么样？答案可能不是太美妙，可能感觉不太好，因为你永远不希望一段关系呈现出如此极端的不平衡状态，你知道的，你不会希望感觉有人没有对等你的付出，因为这说明了他们对你的尊重、对你们联系的尊重、对你们关系的尊重到底是什么样的呢？我认为发起关于这些事情的对话需要消耗大量的精神能量，也许你没有这个精力。你将自己本就有限的认知
space and time to this one side of relationship. But I think it's worth it, and there is a way to approach this and this conversation in a manner that gets kind of the best outcome and the solution for everyone. I really don't think it's a matter of like, oh, this person, you know, my partner is not taking on the mental load, failing to communicate that that's what you need done and then just leaving them without giving them a chance to maybe adapt their behavior. And I think the same thing goes with friendship. The older we get, the further into our 20s, I think the more we realize that you can't just cut people off willy-nilly. You can't just have issues and not communicate them because you will end up just hurting yourself more as those
空间和时间更多地奉献给了关系的这一方面。但我认为这是值得的，而且有一种方法可以以能够为每个人带来最佳结果和解决方案的方式来处理这件事和这场对话。我真的不认为这是一个诸如“哦，这个人，你知道的，我的伴侣没有承担心智负担”，却没有沟通这就是你需要他们做的事，然后就把他们晾在一边而不给他们机会去调整行为的问题。我认为友谊也是如此。我们年龄越大，步入二十岁越深，我想我们就越意识到你不能随心所欲地跟人绝交。你不能只是遇到问题却不沟通，因为随着这些关系走向破裂，
relationships break down. So what we're going to talk about next is how to manage a conversation about the mental load in your relationship, how to kind of get to a place where there is a solution either in your friendships, your relationships and other forms of connections that you might have. So all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs. when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness,
最终只会给自己带来更多的伤害。所以我们接下来要谈的是，如何在恋爱关系中就心智负担展开对话，如何在友谊、恋爱关系以及你可能拥有的其他形式的联系中，找到一个能够达成解决方案的境地。所有这些以及更多内容，将在短暂的广告之后为您呈现。《2%》。当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数占比只有2%。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神韧性、
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils
体能以及在奇妙的现代世界中建立适应力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油
were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
本质上具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字 2 加上 percent，可在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击了莉儿·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
乔治·布什跟莉儿·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并尝试理清我们是如何熬过那段岁月的。包括最近一期节目中，马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈80年代的霹雳可卡因。需要澄清的是，1984年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备好在白天谈论可卡因，只是为了让你们大家都知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
我的意思是，此时此刻，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二期节目了。我开始看出这其中有一条贯穿始终的线索了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你把那句话说完。我认为对于黑人来说，再没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at It。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖姆斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross.
有时我们在追求某物时，会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于我们没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。
you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free I Heart Radio app.
你觉得在世期间做一个好人有多重要？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。当然是。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正成为一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯（Keir Gaines），在我的新播客《难走的路》（Learn the Hard Way）中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 I Heart Radio 应用程序。
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself. at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct?
搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法院听证会揭露了她口中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法庭之战，只为证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的检测结果，对吧？
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
我只篡改了一次检测结果。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破获此案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款都用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。
Michael Sbian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
迈克尔·斯比亚恩（Michael Sbian）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《情网难逃》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在正义在亚利桑那州伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When you feel that you're taking on more of the mental load in relationship, that is going to have a number of bleed on effects, a lot of impacts, not just on the relationship, but your health as well. The primary one, I think, is burnout, of course. A lot of research on this has been done with mothers, who don't only have partners, but children to look after it as well. Nearly nine and ten mothers in this one study. felt that they were solely responsible for managing and organizing the family's schedule, and it left them feeling overwhelmed, exhausted, unable to make space for themselves.
在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当你觉得自己在一段关系中承担了更多的精神负担时，这会产生一系列的连锁反应，产生很多影响，不仅对关系本身，对你的健康也是如此。我认为主要的影响当然是精疲力竭。这方面的大多数研究都是针对母亲进行的，她们不仅有伴侣，还要照顾孩子。在这项研究中，几乎十分之九的母亲觉得她们要独自负责管理和安排家庭的日程，这让她们感到不堪重负、筋疲力尽，无法为自己留出空间。
Similar study found that 72% of working moms, so not just stay-at-home moms, working moms feel that it's their job to stay on top of kids' schedules. 52% of them are also facing burnout. So when we think about this from a more psychological perspective, right? We really do only have a finite amount of mental space, cognitive space, mental resources. There are always things that are going to be competing for our time. That includes things like work, personal things that you're going through, personal dilemmas, friendships, making time to exercise, making time to prioritize yourself. When we feel like we are responsible,
一项类似的研究发现，72% 的职业妈妈——不仅仅是全职妈妈，职业妈妈——觉得掌控孩子的日程是她们的工作。其中 52% 的人也面临着精疲力竭。所以，当我们从更心理学的角度来思考这个问题时，对吧？我们的精神空间、认知空间和心理资源确实是有限的。总是有各种事情在争夺我们的时间。这包括工作、你正在经历的个人事务、个人困境、友谊、抽出时间锻炼、抽出时间优先考虑自己。当我们觉得我们有责任时……
for organizing someone else's life and the life that we share together, that is just more that is being taken out of this finite pool of what is available to us mentally. And it's going to lead to exhaustion if other parts of our lives don't make space for that growth in that area. I think it's important to see it this way and see it almost as like how we want to visualize it, whether it's like a cup or a pie or anything. Like you really only have that much. Everything that you choose to put on your plate, you choose to devote your time to, your energy to, your love to takes away from that finite amount of thing that you have. And so what it requires you to do is sacrifice other things that are important to you. And those are the kinds of sacrifices
……去组织别人的生活以及我们共同的生活，这只会从我们精神上可用的有限资源池中抽取更多。如果生活中的其他部分没有为该领域的成长留出空间，这将导致筋疲力竭。我认为以这种方式看待它很重要，几乎可以将其视作我们想要将其可视化的一种方式，无论是像一个杯子、一个饼干还是别的什么。就像你真的只有那么多一样。你选择放在盘子里的每件事、你选择投入时间、精力、爱的事，都会从你拥有的有限数量中扣除。因此，它要求你牺牲对你来说很重要的其他事情。而这些正是……
that women often have to make more than men. Those things that they sacrifice, first are normally going to be the things that they can live without but they can't sustain themselves without things that actually contribute to self-care to a good sense of emotional well-being. If you have a really busy life, if you've got a lot going on and you know that you need to prioritize work, you need to prioritize your partner, you need to prioritize your family and you don't have time for anything else. The things that are going to get chopped that are going to get discarded is going to be things like exercise. It's going to be things like seeing your friends, things that are important for your self-care, that is going to further the cycle of burnout.
……女性往往比男性做出更多牺牲的事情。她们牺牲的那些东西，首先通常是那些没有它们也能活下去，但没有它们就无法维持自身生存的东西，即那些真正有助于自我照顾、带来良好情感健康感的东西。如果你过着非常忙碌的生活，如果你有很多事情要做，并且你知道你需要优先处理工作，你需要优先处理你的伴侣，你需要优先处理你的家庭，而且你没有时间做其他事情，那么将被砍掉、将被丢弃的东西就会是像锻炼这样的事情。它将是见朋友这样的事情，这些对你的自我照顾很重要的事，这会进一步加剧精疲力竭的循环。
That is the main impact. I also think that you just start feeling that exhaustion long before you feel burnt out and that exhaustion also contributes to a sense of resentment in your relationship. You don't feel respected because this person is not contributing what you feel like you are contributing. They did a study on this back in 2001, right when the mental load was really starting to take off. And they found that when women in particular feel they're doing more of the cognitive labor, the amount of satisfaction they report in their relationship declines. More mental load, less happy in relationship. It's a very, I think, simple, correlation. When you're at that point where you're feeling really disappointed in your partner,
这是主要的冲击。我也认为，早在你感到精疲力竭之前，你就会开始感受到那种疲惫，而这种疲惫也会导致你在感情中产生一种怨恨感。你感觉不到被尊重，因为这个人没有付出你觉得你所付出的东西。早在2001年，就在精神负担真正开始流行的时候，他们就对此做过一项研究。他们发现，尤其是当女性觉得自己承担了更多的认知劳动时，她们对关系的满意度报告就会下降。精神负担越多，关系越不幸福。我认为这是一个非常简单的相关性。当你到了对伴侣感到非常失望的地步时……
but as we said before, you're not quite sure why, because the mental load and cognitive labor isn't as recognized as domestic labor. What you're going to do is unconsciously, subconsciously find ways to get their attention, find ways to bring them into a discussion in which you're allowed to kind of air your anger and air your resentment. What I'm talking about here is emotional bids. Now we've spoken about this on the show before. I can't remember one episode, but essentially emotional bids are like these efforts that we make to bring our partner's attention to some problem and have them re-assure us. The best example I think of is picking a fight. Or, you know, being like to your partner, oh, hey, look at this and then they don't look at it
……但正如我们之前所说，你又不太确定原因，因为精神负担和认知劳动不像家务劳动那样容易被认可。你要做的是在无意识、潜意识中寻找方法来引起他们的注意，寻找方法让他们参与到一场允许你宣泄愤怒和宣泄怨恨的讨论中。我这里所说的是情感试探（emotional bids）。现在我们以前在节目中讨论过这个。我不记得是哪一集了，但本质上，情感试探就像是我们为了将伴侣的注意力吸引到某个问题上并让他们安抚我们而做出的这些努力。我想最好的例子就是挑起争端。或者，你知道的，对你的伴侣说，哦，嘿，看这个，然后他们根本不看……
and your emotional bid has been neglected. Essentially what you're asking from your partner, in those moments is for attention and is for their compassion, is for like them to contribute to the partnership. When you start to pick fights and you don't even know what the problem is, I find that you're probably not going to find a solution to it either. And it's just going to end up wearing down on both of you, creating a lot of stress, further exacerbating that resentment and leading to relationship breakdown.
……而你的情感试探就被忽视了。本质上，你在那些时刻向伴侣索求的是关注、同情，以及让他们为这段伙伴关系做出贡献。当你开始挑起争端甚至不知道问题出在哪里时，我发现你大概也找不到解决问题的办法。这最终只会消磨你们两个人的精力，造成大量的压力，进一步加剧这种怨恨，并导致关系的破裂。
And I've seen this happen in a friend of mine's relationship, where after just so many times of trying to get her partner to do more for her, to just plan things, to just like not have to ask her constantly, hey, where's dinner tonight? What time? What am I meant to be wearing? Did you get my mum a birthday present? Like, she had asked so many times for him to understand where she was coming from
我曾在我的一个朋友的感情中看到过这种情况，在无数次试图让她的伴侣为她做更多事情、去计划事情、而不是总是不得不问她“嘿，今晚晚饭吃什么？几点？我该穿什么？你给我妈买生日礼物了吗？”之后……她曾无数次请求他理解她的处境……
that the relationship ended up not working out because she realized that he couldn't be a good partner. And I felt bad for him because I think that he had such an opportunity. there to correct his behavior, all he required was a bit more empathy. So I want to talk about how we can fix this dynamic in which you might be taking on more of the mental load. I think the first step in any relationship dispute, whatever you want to call it, dissatisfaction, problem, whatnot, is to make sure you were both on the same page about what the problem is. So maybe a good first step is to actually send them this episode, not just trying to get more listens or anything like that. But seriously, like, I think it's really important that if they have never even heard of what the
……以至于这段关系最终无法维持下去，因为她意识到他无法成为一个好伴侣。我为他感到难过，因为我认为他在那里本有极好的机会去纠正自己的行为，他所需要的只是多一点同理心。所以我想谈谈我们如何解决这种动态，在这种动态中你可能承担了更多的精神负担。我认为任何关系纠纷中的第一步，无论你想怎么称呼它——不满、问题之类的，就是确保你们两个对问题是什么达成共识。所以也许一个好的第一步其实是把这一集发给他，而不仅仅是为了获得更多的收听率什么的。但说真的，我认为非常重要的一点是，如果他们甚至从未听说过什么是……
mental load is, if they have no clue what you're talking about, that conversation is not going to be productive. And I also think that, I think sadly, the conversation will fail because they will immediately be defensive. Not to say that they should be, but I think that going into it with a mutual understanding of what you want to discuss and what you're actually referring to is super important. Maybe they listen to this episode. They go, oh my God, absolutely. I totally get where you're coming from. We don't need to talk about it anymore. I'm going to step up. After you have that genuine like mutual understanding, mutual knowledge, you have to decide whether you're going to tolerate a continuance of this behavior or not. That is not a conclusion that I can reach for you.
……精神负担，如果他们对你在说什么一无所知，那么这种对话就不会有成效。而且我也认为，遗憾的是，对话会失败，因为他们会立即开启防御心理。并不是说他们应该这样，但我认为带着对你想讨论的内容以及你实际在指什么有一致的理解进入对话是超级重要的。也许他们听了这一集。然后他们会说，哦天哪，完全正确。我完全理解你的意思。我们不需要再谈这个了。我要加把劲了。在有了这种真诚的、相互理解、相互了解之后，你必须决定是否还要容忍这种行为的持续。这不是我能为你得出的结论。
I don't know the pros and cons of your relationship. I don't know your dynamic. But you know, you know your emotional state. You know what you can tolerate. You know what you're willing to tolerate, not just what you can, what you're willing to, what you feel like you deserve. And if you're at this stage where you are so mentally fed up,
我不知道你这段感情的利弊。我不知道你们的相处模式。但你知道，你了解自己的情绪状态。你知道你能容忍什么。你知道你愿意容忍什么，不仅是你能够的，还有你愿意的，以及你觉得自己应得的。如果你正处于这种精神上已经受够了的阶段……
you're having the same fights over and over again, that is a good indicator that the ceiling of your relationship needs to shift upwards, particularly that someone is not doing their bit, especially as it refers to the mental load. I think when it comes to having this conversation around a sense of dissatisfaction that someone's not pulling their weight, sadly the burden will probably fall on you to bring this up and discuss it with your partner. But hopefully it's a one-time chat. I would say going into this, make sure obviously, firstly, they know what you're talking about, but also be mindful of the responsibility bias. So this is this idea in psychology that basically we are only really aware,
……你们一遍又一遍地吵着同样的架，这是一个很好的迹象，表明你们关系的上限需要向上调整，尤其是某人没有尽到自己的责任，特别是在精神负担方面。我认为，当谈到围绕“某人没有尽到责任”这种不满感进行对话时，遗憾的是，提出这一点并与伴侣讨论的重担可能还是会落到你身上。但希望这是一次性的谈话。我想说的是，在进入谈话时，首先确保他们知道你在说什么，但也要注意责任偏差（responsibility bias）。这就是心理学上的这种观点，基本上我们只真正意识到……
fully aware of what we're doing. We only know what we're responsible for. We only know our actions. We only know the times that we cleaned out the bin, not the times that you did, you know. And if you haven't verbalized the efforts that you're going to to keep the house up to scratch or to contribute to the relationship, it might be hard for them to know. And they're immediately going to come in with their perspective and their perspective is, in my mind, here are all the things I'm doing. I have absolutely no clue how much you're doing. That is where communication is your best friend. Give them literal examples, but try not to guilt-trip them in the process. Remember, you want this to work, like you want this relationship to work. That's why you're
……完全意识到我们在做什么。我们只知道我们负责什么。我们只知道我们的行动。我们只知道我们清理垃圾桶的次数，而不是你清理的次数，你知道的。如果你没有用言语表达出你为了保持家里整洁或为这段关系做出贡献而付出的努力，他们可能很难知道。他们会立即带着他们自己的视角介入，而他们的视角在我的脑海里是这样的：这些是我在做的事情。我完全不知道你在做多少。这就是为什么沟通是你最好的朋友。给他们具体的例子，但在此过程中尽量不要让他们产生负罪感。记住，你希望这段关系成功，就像你希望这段关系能够长久一样。这就是为什么你……
putting in this effort. Talk them through what it takes for you to do all this extra mental labor. what does your to-do list look like? What is the extra steps, extra ingredients that you're putting into this relationship that they could take on? Is it planning dates? Is it understanding when flights need to be booked for a weekend away? Is it making plans? Is it just listening and being aware of your schedule the way that you're aware of theirs? These are all small, important things that they might not realize you've been doing until you communicate them.
……付出了这些努力。向他们详细说明你做所有这些额外的精神劳动需要付出什么。你的待办事项清单是什么样的？你为这段关系投入的额外步骤、额外成分是什么，是他们可以承担的？是规划约会吗？是了解周末出游的机票什么时候预订吗？是制定计划吗？还是仅仅像你关注他们的日程那样去倾听并关注你的日程？这些都是很小但很重要的事情，在与他们沟通之前，他们可能并没有意识到你一直在做。
Something that a friend of mine was telling me the other day, which when I was asking her about this episode, I was like, okay, so what would you do in this situation? And she used this really, she gave me this really amazing advice, which is put a list of everything that you do each week on the fridge, everything that needs to be done, and each person gets a different coloured pen, and you tick them off. It sounds so rudimentary, but it's really important to actually be like, is my resentment coming from a fair place, or is my partner actually doing an equal amount of labor? It's just that I have this responsibility. bias going on, I can't actually see what they're doing. Also, you can use some of that
我的一个朋友前几天跟我说了一件事，当时我向她询问这一集的内容，我说，好吧，在这种情况下你会怎么做？她用了这个非常……她给了我一个非常棒的建议，那就是在冰箱上列出你每周所做的一切、所有需要完成的事情，每个人用不同颜色的笔，然后把它们勾掉。这听起来太基础了，但非常重要，能让你真正去想：我的怨恨是来自一个公平的地方，还是我的伴侣实际上付出了同等数量的劳动？只是我身上存在这种责任偏差，我实际上看不到他们在做什么。此外，你还可以使用一些……
reverse reinforcement, you know, if they don't buy the birthday present for their mom, the mom doesn't get a birthday present. That is some negative punishment right there. They're going to feel really bad. They're going to feel the shame. It wasn't your responsibility. They're going to learn through that. If they don't plan the date, you go and do something else because they didn't make plans, even if you're in a relationship. I know it sounds harsh, but it is this thing of like, you need to continuously be dating me in a sense.
……逆向强化（reverse reinforcement），你知道的，如果他们不给自己的妈妈买生日礼物，妈妈就收不到生日礼物。这就是一种负惩罚。他们会感到非常糟糕。他们会感到羞耻。这不是你的责任。他们会从中吸取教训。如果他们没有规划约会，你就自己去做别的事，因为他们没有做计划，即使你正处于一段恋爱关系中。我知道这听起来很刺耳，但这是一种这样的事情：在某种程度上，你需要不断地跟我约会。
And if you're not, like, I am not just like your backup option. You're not just my backup option. We are like actively trying to be partners and be in each other's lives and make each other's lives better and easier and more vibrant. And if that's not what we're doing right now,
如果你不这样做，那么我不仅仅是你的备选。你也不仅仅是我的备选。我们是在积极地努力成为伴侣，进入彼此的生活，让彼此的生活变得更好、更轻松、更有活力。如果这并不是我们现在正在做的事情……
I am going to find other ways to do that. I need you to step up. It might sound harsh. I think it works. especially when it's combined with really good communication and a really good open dialogue of like how are you both actually feeling right now and how are you feeling that you're taking on more of the mental load? What are some of the things that they might not know that it is creating for your mental state, for your limited cognitive resources, for your well-being, over-communicate
……我将寻找其他方法来做到这一点。我需要你加把劲。这听起来可能很刺耳。但我认为它管用，尤其是当它与非常好的沟通以及非常好的开放式对话相结合时，比如你们俩现在到底是什么感觉？你是否觉得你承担了更多的精神负担？对于你的精神状态、你有限的认知资源、你的幸福感，他们可能不知道它正在造成什么，过度沟通……
and then let them make a decision. You cannot control what they choose to do without information. if you find yourself continuing to just having to ask them and nag them and bring it up again and again and again, I think that is a different conversation. That is no longer a conversation about mental load. I think that is a conversation about disrespect and a lack of empathy. And maybe it's important to start thinking about when it is time to walk away and find someone who you don't need to tell this to. They already know how to do it.
……然后让他们做决定。在没有信息的情况下，你无法控制他们选择做什么。如果你发现自己继续不得不去要求他们、唠叨他们、一遍又一遍地提起这件事，我认为这是另一种性质的对话。那不再是关于精神负担的对话。我认为那是关于不尊重和缺乏同理心的对话。也许开始考虑什么时候该离开，去找一个不需要你告诉他这些的人，这很重要。他们已经知道该怎么做……
they already have done the work, they've already learned what it means to be an equal partner. It's not just domestic labor. It's not just physical labor. It is cognitive labor as well, being equally responsible for the life that you share. I really hope that this episode, this fun Valentine's Day episode has been helpful. I'm realizing that it got a little bit less fun at the end. But I think it is an important reminder that just because you love this person, just because they're like your soulmate, doesn't mean that you have to be dissatisfied with areas of your relationship.
……他们已经付出了努力，他们已经学会了作为一个平等的伴侣意味着什么。这不仅仅是家务劳动。这不仅仅是体力劳动。这也是认知劳动，对你们共同的生活负有同等的责任。我真心希望这一集，这个有趣的情人节特辑能对大家有所帮助。我意识到它在结尾时变得没那么有趣了。但我认为这是一个重要的提醒：仅仅因为你爱这个人，仅仅因为他们就像你的灵魂伴侣，并不意味着你必须对关系中的某些领域感到不满意。
Doesn't mean you need to tolerate something that can be fixed through a conversation and through like reverse reinforcement and learning and reconditioning. So I really enjoyed this episode. I found it like super fascinating to look further into the science and the psychology. As I said, my very good friend Aaron actually suggested this topic and she knew so much more than I ever did. So thank you, Aaron. Love you heaps. I'm glad that our relationship does not suffer from mental load problems.
并不意味着你必须容忍那些可以通过对话、通过逆向强化、学习和重新塑造来解决的问题。所以我真的很喜欢这一集。我发现深入研究科学和心理学超级着迷。正如我所说，我非常要好的朋友艾伦（Aaron）实际上建议了这个话题，她知道的远比我多得多。所以谢谢你，艾伦。非常爱你。我很高兴我们的关系没有受到精神负担问题的困扰。
If there's someone you think would enjoy this episode, please feel free to share it with them, send them a link. Make sure you are leaving us a five-star review if you enjoyed this episode. If you have an episode suggestion, they have been flowing in recently, but I always do like to read them, even if I cannot reply to every single one, please follow us at that psychology podcast to send your thoughts, your theories, your qualms, your questions to us there. And have a lovely rest of your week. We will be back on Friday with another episode. Two percent. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some
如果你身边有人会喜欢这一集，请随时与他们分享，发送链接。如果你喜欢这一集，请确保给我们留下五星好评。如果你有节目建议，最近它们一直在源源不断地涌入，但我总是喜欢阅读它们，即使我无法回复每一个建议，也请在那个心理学播客关注我们，将你的想法、理论、烦恼和问题发送给我们。祝你余下的周过得愉快。我们周五将带着另一集回归。百分之二。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理坚韧、健康和构建韧性的科学。经历一些……
hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
……艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 TWO%。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back At It》播客中。
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians,
从1979年开始，这对我和说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过这段时期的。同我们的朋友、喜剧同行……
and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games.
……以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）主持的《难走的路》（Learn the Hard Way）。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct?
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在任何地方说其实都不安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在 AHA Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你曾两次篡改这个特定的检测结果，欧文斯女士，对吧？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
我篡改了一次检测结果。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《情网难逃》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个 IHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。